think what feels right to me is
approaching this entire week
not having sex with fantasy suites well
it didn't take long for bachelor star
Zach shalcross to break that promise the
whole night was a very passionate night
for Gabby and I something really special
happened between us and the fantasy
suite after not sticking to his no sex
rule with Gabby she struggles to cope
with the aftermath I do feel like my
trust was broken
because I felt like it was between us
now it's between us plus everyone else
always you know show your emotion always
you know communicate how you're feeling
throughout the whole journey even though
it's tough you have to be vulnerable the
drama unfolds as Zach travels to
Thailand with his three final women
Ariel Gabby and Katie I can see a future
with all three of these women and it's
just more reaffirming that this is
working and from the start he's been
pretty clear with his intentions for the
overnight dates I guess what I
Vision was
that this week in particular
um sex being off the table however when
it comes to his alone time with Gabby I
won't try to seduce you
Zach's plans kind of changed how are you
feeling I'm feeling great
you do
waking up this morning I am feeling
a lot of
like incredible feelings
last night was really important for us
Zack's guilt gets the best of him and
when he decides to tell the other ladies
about their night Gabby is not happy I
didn't realize we were so bothered
yeah I'm feeling a little bit blindsided
because everything that's meant to be
like
private and between us is now like not
any longer like I preach honesty from
the very beginning and if you ever have
to force it especially
in this experience when when time is so
limited you know I don't want to waste
her time Zach does come clean to Katie
about what went down with Gabby and she
takes the news well as expected I get
that you wanted to tell me and I know
like you're saying that because you
respect me but like honestly just like
could have went without hearing that
oops
well I'm crushed in the end the bachelor
frontman gives both Gabby and Katie his
two final roses sending Ariel home I
thought I'd be a lot happier and right
now I feel like I am like I said wearing
a big a on my chest and it seems come
the finale Zach's still dealing with the
consequences of his actions I have
questions that are running through my
mind that I need answered before I can
confidently move forward with an
engagement oh it's Katie and Gabby are
still feeling upset with me do you
regret the decision that you made with
me on the back of my head is like is he
saying to Gabby I'm sick of self-doubt
I'm sick of feeling like I don't know if
I'm enough are you happy
I'll tell you this I'm very happy and I
did find love but to see what that looks
like you're gonna have to turn it you
know that's that's what I gotta say
foreign